he's Mike Florio from ProFootballTalk
the NBC sports network and also NBC
radio you can hear it and watch it right
before this program six to nine a.m.
eastern every day Monday through Friday
on the NBC Sports Network all right Mike
first of all summarize what the
commissioners letter and the initiative
was of this hundred-million-dollar
safety campaign well it's a very
wide-ranging attempt to continue the
efforts to number one prevent
concussions number to ensure that
players who have concussions are getting
proper treatment before they're put back
on the field and they are taking this
very seriously if you look at it and say
it's for PR and to a certain extent it
is but they also are trying to solve the
problem they're talking about developing
new helmets helmets that are specific to
the positions that players play because
you have different types of blows to the
head based upon whether you're an
offensive lineman or running back or
receiver or a defensive back and they
think that within three to five years
they'll have helmets that can greatly
reduce concussions I ultimately can
eliminate them because when the human
body is moving and abruptly stops the
brain bounces off the inside of the
skull and can be damaged but they keep
trying to make the game safer whether
it's minimizing kickoff returns which
isn't going so well so far this year but
they are looking for ways to make the
game safer they're taking it seriously
because they do understand that if you
choke off the supply of football players
because their parents won't let them
play because the sport is perceived to
be too dangerous your altima not going
to have an NFL why doesn't the NFL have
a targeting rule a college does yeah I
heard you talking about that and it's
great stuff and I'm going to find out
whether or not this is something that
would have to go through the collective
bargaining process I don't know that
they could change the rules that
dramatically without Union consent maybe
they can but that's a big deal that you
can eject the player and discipline a
player for that type of an infraction
when that's not a rule that's currently
on the books and it could be that
they're just not prepared to go to the
bargaining table and make a concession
to the union in order to get the ability
to eject players for targeting that
would be one potential explanation and
maybe that's the only one because the FL
prides itself and on having rule chain
that trickled down to lower levels the
sport it shouldn't be that a rule change
is trickling up a rule change the
promotes player safety and tries to get
players to play the game a certain way
Brandon Marshall of the Broncos
yesterday said that the Broncos aren't
dirty because they don't twist ankles
and gouge eyes but when you are playing
with a level of reckless abandon that
doesn't take into account the obligation
you have to not throw your helmet into
the body of a quarterback you are
playing dirty because you are playing
with willful ignorance deliberate
ignorance of what the rules require and
you are taking those risks by using your
helmet as a weapon even though you
aren't deliberately trying to injure the
guys and and I don't know what the
process would be but if you do view
somebody as targeting like Brandon
Marshall did to cam newton Brandon
Marshall has nothing to lose here what
15 yards maybe he gets fine 20 grand if
you you know ding the bell of Cam Newton
or knock him out of the game well I
would do that if I'm a defensive player
I'm a hero remember that day it was
October 17 2010 where there were three
vicious helmet-to-helmet hits in real
time we were watching the games at the
NBC studio at the time at 30 rock and
within five minutes it was Brandon
Meriweather on Todd Heap it was James
Harrison on mohamed massaquoi and it was
dunta robinson on DeSean Jackson and
that sparked a conversation and Rodney
Harrison made the point that night on
football night in America I set money
aside for the fines yeah I don't care
about the fund the only thing is going
to stop me from playing like that is
being taken off the field for a week and
we still haven't seen the kind of
increase in suspensions that maybe we
need to have and it sure felt like
something was going on Thursday night
and it reminded me of the NFC
Championship game saints vikings the
bounty game where they were doing
everything they could and not favre out
of the game I felt like the Broncos
strategically not because anybody was
given anybody an envelope with a hundred
dollars in it but strategically deciding
to go after Cam Newton to either knock
him out of the game or to render him
less effective because he's been banged
around and it worked we're talking to
Mike Florio from ProFootballTalk I I
still don't understand what happened on
Monday night with Antonio Brown and Josh
Norman I at some point if I'm Jay Gruden
I say I can I Antonio Browns getting
open he's still but he's pretty good
why wouldn't I have Josh Norman on him
now you have dez bryant and the cowboys
next game is josh norman going to be on
one side and dez brian is going to be on
the other eye and you know this is
apparently what they did in carolina
most of the time he was on one side so i
don't know how he ends up on Odell
Beckham jr. all the time just put Odell
Beckham jr. where Josh Norman isn't yes
so I the Washington seems to be locked
into this idea of keeping Norman on one
side of the field they had a lot of
faith in mashhad Breeland and I think
they still do it's just a Antonio Brown
is that good and Ben Roethlisberger who
doesn't get nearly enough credit for
what he's become late in his career he's
getting better all the time he's putting
those balls in there that are almost
impossible to vend even Dion Sanders in
his prime would have a hard time with
this but the bottom line is you're going
to pay a guy 15 million a year and
you're going to tell them you just stay
on this side of the field now that works
if you're the Seahawks and you have the
rest of the Legion of boom when the
packers for example decide they're just
going to ignore Josh Norman week 1 of
2014 and not Josh Norman Richard Sherman
and throw the ball on the other side of
the field when you don't have the rest
of the secondary to backup Josh Norman
that's not going to work for Washington
so they better start thinking about
putting him on the number one receiver
every week or number one this is going
to keep happening at number two they're
never going to get their money's worth
how much pressure is on the Rams now
given that performance if you want to
call that in San Francisco and you see
Carson Wentz starting for Philadelphia
Jared golf maybe as the backup
quarterback and I'm looking at maybe
down the road they host Buffalo in a few
weeks maybe that's where you unveil him
but do you think the Rams are inching
closer and closer to putting golf in
there well here's the thing that struck
me the most significant thing I saw
Monday night case keenum had a C on his
jersey he's a captain on that team he
was voted a captain by the players after
the offseason program pre-season
training camp etc they have their vote
and they make Keenum a captain knowing
the Jared Goff is the chosen one knowing
that the team moved from 15 to number
one specifically to get here at goth
what does that tell you if the players
think Keenum is a cabinet that tells me
the kingdom's their quarterback and the
goth isn't and they know that there's a
gap there and it's alarming when you
think you know this isn't the Rams I
learning the number one overall pick and
say hey we got to pick somebody this is
the Rams at number 15 saying we are
moving up from 15 to 1 because Goff is
our guy and it's glaring that he wasn't
in uniform on Monday night and now you
have to ask yourself at what point do
they just throw caution to the wind and
what kind of problems is that going to
cause in the locker room when the
veterans have already spoken that Keenum
is there captain Kingdom is their
quarterback thank you Mike I that's Mike
Florio from ProFootballTalk the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience